so you've battled the legendary palkia
and dialga and you chill near the
pasture with these two behemoths
thinking life is good
but you remember that maybe there was
this third legendary and you were like
wait a sec i want to catch it too now
you realize the story didn't just end
despite you already hitting the credits
and that there's a post game campaign
quest waiting for you oh and do you
remember there were also those little
floating bits of ember around the region
yeah there's like 106 of them and also
why is everyone on twitter posting
pictures of shiny pokemon
don't fret i'm gonna break down all the
content the end game of pokemon legends
arceus has to offer and what
specifically you should look forward to
and pursue drop a like follow me on
twitter sub to this channel and let's
get to it
[Music]
alright first things first you gotta
find the five missing arceus plates
there are 18 and all with the main story
giving you 12 as you progress throughout
the game once you hit the post game
kagita mentions there are five still
missing and she mentions where you can
find the missing plates most of them
involve chasing down mythical pokemon
however the easiest one is to go
straight to prelude beach and battle
commander kamado his team is no joke and
if your pokemon are at a decent enough
level you'll still be able to make quick
work of him obtaining the fight plate
now you can chase down the remaining
four plates in any order that you choose
still i strongly recommend you go after
heatrin for two simple reasons heatrin
drops the iron plate which you'll need
for another legendary there are also a
lot of mudballs that spawn in when you
start the encounter with him and the
volcano at firespit island you will want
to run around grabbing as many of these
mud balls as possible because they'll
come in real handy for starters they
pretty much remove any need to battle
the legendary and mythical pokemon and
they make the encounters easy as hell
just chuck the mud balls at them to stun
and then attempt to back strike with the
lead-in or another type of heavy ball
and just rinse and repeat
next we've got moon view arena to catch
cresselia careful when you approach her
though because cresselia has a pretty
annoying confusion attack that will
immediately invert your controls if
you're hit by it
in terms of handling the encounter the
same rules apply throw the mud balls and
profit soon after it is reggie gigas up
at snow temple and if the wall in the
snow temple remains closed chances are
you're missing one of the required
arceus plates make sure you have the
stone ice and iron plates and then
access to regi gigas will be granted
inside the temple after you're done
there it is time to chase down three
more mythical pokemon go to each of the
lakes where yuxi azolf and mesprit
reside and catch them they're fairly
painless as long as you have enough
mudballs and you keep hitting them with
the lead and back strikes once you catch
all three you'll get the final missing
plate that kagita requested only issue
is when you return to kagita and volo
they'll mention that there is still one
extra plate missing go through the
remaining story beats and cutscenes
before meeting up with volo at the spear
pillar where you previously fought
palkia and dialga i'm gonna tell you
right now volo and his stupid finger wag
have the final plate and a quick word of
warning definitely have your strongest
team with you and be stocked up on
supplies because things can get a little
dicey from this point if you walk in
unprepared a climactic battle awaits
with literally three battles back to
back so be sure to save your game before
triggering the fight you'll have to deal
with volo's team which is pretty stacked
and worthy of a champion in any of the
other games but the real surprise occurs
right after the battle as giratina will
soon appear and attack
do not bother trying to catch this one
because you can't your only choice is to
make it faint not just in one but both
of its regular and origin form when
you've done this you are more or less
finished with any main narrative points
in the game and now it is time to dig
into all of the remaining loose ends
everyone loves the starters and odds are
you'd like to get as many of the
starters as possible right well to get
to the remaining two legends arceus
starters and their hassui and forms
simply talk to lavinton in his office
easy right
space-time distortion riffs are
incredible and they have so many awesome
and rare items on the ground for you to
pick up you'll also find a lot of strong
and rare pokemon within those riffs get
the jump on some of the evolution stones
or trading by catching an already
evolved flareon or gengar right off the
bat it feels awesome and you'll want to
explore as many space time rifts as
possible since different pokemon will
spawn in different rifts
turn back cave is up next because i know
you might be a little salty that you
couldn't catch giratina right off the
bat do not worry the legendary is
waiting for you just fine in the
turnback cave which can easily be found
near the cobalt coastlands at the top
left of the regional map the strategy
remains the same as the other
legendaries although you may have to
actually battle this time paralysis and
ultra balls are your friends here and
once you've successfully caught giratina
you'll even find a gracious core as well
[Music]
i hope you're not tired of all these
legendaries and mythical pokemon to
chase because we got an influx of a
couple more we now have the legendary
trio of gen 5 which will appear with
certain weather conditions you've got
tornadoes which can be found in the bone
chill waist near the alabaster icelands
and he'll only appear during a blizzard
thundurus on the other hand will appear
over the sea and the cobalt coastlines
only if heavy rain is pouring and lastly
the third of the trio is landorus and
you can catch it in the obsidian field
lands in sunny weather keep in mind that
if you are not getting the weather that
you need simply resting at a camp tent
can be enough to change the weather if
you cause the legendaries to faint too
don't worry just leave the area and rest
and return right back under the right
conditions and they'll have respawned
but if you're paranoid like me then
simply just save the game before you
encounter them once you catch all three
you might think that's it right but wait
there's more there's a brand new pokemon
that debuts and legends arceus for the
first time ever enamorous which is a
fairy type enamores will only be
approachable after you get the research
level for the trio to level 10 and if
you can complete enamores pokedex entry
as well you will receive a reveal glass
item which will transform landorus
thunderous and tornadoes into their
therian forms
a huge chunk of the endgame's appeal for
me personally is chasing all these
legendaries down but legends arceus has
plenty of side quests for players to
complete too that are also connected to
some of these mythical pokemon two side
quests in particular are connected to
shaman and darkrai however to unlock
axes to the quest you will need save
files from brilliant diamond or shining
pearl and sword or shield if you do have
save files on your switch just go to the
request board near lavinton and you'll
find two new quests that reference
shaymin and darkrai
[Music]
now is also a good time to chip away at
some of the lengthier fetch quests such
as collecting all 28 unknown pokemon as
well as those floating embers that are
required to obtain spirit tomb spirit
tomb's embers are scattered well out
among the region and they will be sure
to keep players busy for a good chunk of
time while we've got all this collecting
momentum it is a good time to complete
the pokedex as much as we can to gain
access to the ultimate final pokemon
arceus itself to do this you will need a
complete pokedex which means catching a
bunch and leveling those pokemon up to
evolve and carrying out the various
tasks that the pokedex requires
[Music]
suppose you'd rather battle your pokemon
instead of catching them in that case
there are repeatable encounters that you
can farm with any team to give yourself
some challenges for starters all the
noble pokemon you dealt with throughout
the story they're ready for rematches
with no limit to how many times you can
battle them again their levels are
significantly higher although most
mechanics work the same think of it as
kind of like re-challenging the elite
four in the prior games also be sure to
visit the training grounds and talk to
ingo he'll ask you who you'd like to
challenge and you can pick from a wide
variety of different trainers ready to
duke it out the experience gains here
are pretty generous too so if you got
the itch to raise your pokemon to level
100 this is definitely a solid place to
do it eventually you can also face off
against paulkia dialga and arceus once
again but at a far higher level if you
successfully catch arceus the option
will open up for you to challenge off
against palkia dialga and arceus once
again but at a far higher level all you
have to do is you just travel back to
spear pillar and you can battle a level
85 palkia or dialga or a level 100
arceus
now details are scarce but we do know
that legends arcus is expected to have
pokemon home support later in the year
so why not prepare
if you'd like you should start min
maxing your pokemon getting advantageous
nature mints and leveling them up with
competitive moves that suit your battle
strategy this way you'll have a solid
team ready to roll the moment that you
can transfer your pokemon over to
pokemon home
alright last but definitely not least we
have got shiny hunting shiny pokemon for
those of you new to the franchise are
easily some of the most coveted pokemon
in the game with an incredibly rare
encounter raid the odds of encountering
a shiny and legend's arceus is one out
of 4096
basically a
0.024 percent chance however there are
ways to dramatically increase your odds
and they rely on the new outbreak system
in the endgame whenever you embark to
another area the guardsmen will turn and
let you know if an outbreak has been
spotted nearby you can see which pokemon
there is an outbreak of and save your
game before heading to the outbreak if
you don't see a shiny pokemon simply
restart the game the odds for a mass
outbreak shiny end up being about 1 out
of 158 a huge improvement suppose you
have a level 10 entry in the pokedex or
a perfect pokedex and acquired a shiny
charm in that case your odds will
increase even further but the mass
outbreak has an incredibly high floor
for the average player
now it goes without saying that pokemon
legends arceus has incredibly revamped
the pokemon formula but it is nice to
see the end game kind of have a similar
pace to that of the prior games let me
know in the comments what your favorite
part of legends arceus was and what next
legendary pokemon game freak should make
a sequel for until next time
[Music]
you